[Music]
this is the start of this week's podcast
is it yeah
i hadn't coughed yet are you hungry i'll
just get that out you know
done what was that a tackle
yeah you know sometimes when you drink
something very cold it can sometimes
catch your backyard
actually so this is a
fruit smoothie from my favorite fruit
smoothie place and i had a fruit
smoothie i've never had from there
before and it had kale in it and it made
the insides of my legs itch what did i
have on it kale
kale yeah you know that cabbage yeah a
very dense
cabbage and i sometimes feel like it
makes my throat a little bit itchy i
tried it felt fine an hour or so later
the inside of my thighs got quite warm
and itchy were you wearing shorts no i
was in a lovely pair of taxi bombs try
try shorts next thing okay next what's
written on your um your glass there it
doesn't
say dom yes did they write your name on
it it says crazy
why is
i'm hoping it's because that's the name
of the the drink and not me
they didn't just go yeah we've got you
right crazy
maybe
rather than putting people's names on it
they just had to look at people and put
an adjective
let's put down what we think there you
go crazy on your way on your way
handsome yeah i wish
what's been going on this week anything
what's been going on this week tom has
it been all
let me think well you said you'd been
gardening a little bit i did a bit of
gardening yeah because the weather was a
bit nicer wouldn't it be nice i went out
for a surf that was fun caught a couple
of waves that was good
um but uh you know got got it's tax time
hasn't it stopped didn't do your taxes
yet oh that's never fun i don't do it i
have someone do it for me i don't i
don't send me something they say sign
that and they go yeah there you go they
i can't do numbers i actually dreamt
last night that i was doing
not the most complicated
maths in my dream i remember being so
frustrated in my dream thinking really
i'm doing maths this is a dream and i'm
having to do maths in a dream it was
seven plus
one
no
seven times one plus one divided by two
i was like well that's four isn't it
i wasn't listening seven times one right
seven plus one eight divided by two what
is it it's four in it yeah yeah even in
my dream i thought i've got that but i
was just frustrated you could do
anything in a dream so i don't really
want to be doing maths no i think i'm
more of a math head
and you're more of uh letters
love letters have you been doing wordle
yeah i love wordle is that the thing
that comes out once a day yeah my whole
family do it my dad my brother my mum
and i jack's just got me started as well
yeah what are you averaging in terms of
when you're getting it yeah yesterday i
got it with only one lane to go i was
getting scared
i was a five i've done a couple of
threes yeah
i average a three or a four do you mhm
that's good what's your first do you
always have the same first word i don't
always have the same first word but i
try and include two vowels in the first
word because then you kind of covered
yourself so
i tend to i've done laos quite a few
times right okay hello usa yeah uh grime
is a good one that's a good one yeah
yeah
fascinating groat grout that's a good
one i don't think about this week
because i was singing it around the
house
and that song by shaggy mr bombastic yes
i can't remember but i was it was fun
so i think that i get the lyrics wrong
mm-hmm i think you did as well mr
bombastic telephonetastic definitely not
tell a fantastic i think it's
tell me fantastic
and then i sing kiss me on my bottom
center mr oh
monty but i don't think people are
kissing him on his bottom are they no
you you need to know somebody quite well
i don't think you would want that so are
there any lyrics out there that people
either purposefully sing wrong or
accidentally sing wrong another example
would be my best mate tom yeah his
little brother who's not that little
remember we went to a stone rosa's
concert with him he's very tall he's a
big man he's a big lady yeah you don't
want to mess with him
he
used to sing there's a song by the
smiths called girlfriend in a coma
girlfriend's in a coma i know
so he would sing girlfriend in a coma i
know i know she's five today
what what that doesn't even sound like
it and also you wouldn't be going out
with a girl if she was five no unless
you were four or five you know so are
there any lyrics out there that you
knowingly or accidentally sing wrong get
in touch with this is there anything
that you do wrong i think there's
probably quite a lot of telephone
fantastics definitely i thought it was
just really good on the phone yeah tell
me i think it's tell me fantastic
telephonetastic kiss me on my bottom
center mister oh
that's nicer
peeling the onion
well should we do a little bit of
housekeeping let's do it dumb
housekeeping
how much fun are you
to keep a house so clean and true
well we've had a lot of uh
correspondence
we've had great guests we've had a lot
of great guests dom but we need to do
some housekeeping now and just say hello
to the people that have been listening
yes well do you want to start i do off
you go then are you ready you go it's
from dennis
in the netherlands
last episode oh we're at
yeah dennis from the netherlands yes
i loved the friendship onion where you
talk with sam regal about dungeons and
dragons it was so much fun to watch as a
game master myself for a couple of games
with my friends it's really nice to see
people get excited when they learn more
about dungeons and i did get quite
excited yeah
as for the sci-fi tabletop role-playing
game i would suggest
starfinder
it's essentially what you guys talked
about in the podcast it's dungeons and
dragons in space here's my thought
dennis from the netherlands
thank you very much for that i say we
get starfinder i say we get a few of our
friends maybe elijah
sean
maybe maybe dennis from the netherlands
yeah hi dennis whoever and we we play a
game we do it maybe as a special
friendship onion and we start we start
it and i'm the captain i was just about
to say what you're not saying in
brackets which you're going to keep
secret is but i'm the captain yeah i'll
always end with but i'm the captain i
want to be who's the guy in the engine
room that's always confused scotty i
want to be him surrounded by smoke going
i don't think we can make it i don't
think i'm making the head engineer yeah
yeah you can be him i'll be him you'd be
good okay cool yeah i love that thanks
dennis that's great thank you um
we've also had quite a bit of
correspondence about the incredible
scrambled eggs
the incredible scrambled egg making
recipe that our method more than
anything else that i also made at your
house and it was delicious with your
wife
we should we should not forget that i
did baked bread for you you did bake
bread it was fantastic it went very well
this from france
uh from
gael and graham in
samoans in france where is that no i
don't know see my hand
that's quite not a bad shape for francis
if you miss the fingers out right nice
is down here no it's not it's not no
it's up the top nice niece is like here
niece is a southern front well i've
turned it upside down
niece is at the mediterranean is it yeah
you've been oh yeah i was doing a lot of
drinking
who knows where samoans is well i'm
guessing gail and graham do know but
they said uh billy dom and the gang hey
gang
uh thank you so much john i think so
yeah thank you so much for your gordon
ramsay scrambled eggs method made them
today with a mini fry up for lunch
lovely lovely stuff we both approve we
live now in france but originally from
england so a fry up is daily as a daily
miss joy do you have a meal or an
experience from home you still miss
after living in california for so long i
love the show
most of the things that i miss i can
probably get hold of
glasgow and manchester are both known
for having exceptionally good indian
restaurants and i do miss a good indian
meal here and there yeah i know what you
mean tom i found a kind of good indian
but it's not quite the same glasgow is
excellent for indian food i remember we
went out a lot in glasgow for a new food
foreign
what was your place around the corner
from your house that you loved mr sings
i am mr singh i am mr sings and
everybody at mr sings
great i love the restaurant i love the
people fantastic food and they would do
things they i liked how they mixed
scotland with the indian heritage so
they would make a haggis pakora yeah it
was great brilliant eh definitely or
like um
they made a sort of indian
um
curry pie mm-hmm that was yeah oh they
did a lot of cool stuff yeah and there's
a great simplicity in
beans on toast for me and it's not that
easy to get hold of
kind of heinz beans and stuff you can
still find it but it's crazy expensive
for a tin of beans over here isn't it
crazy i know i do miss i know right yeah
like
four or five times more expensive than
uh a tin of beans in in britain so i
like that with the football waking up
early cup of tea maybe beans on toast
maybe a soft fried egg that you can
[ __ ] just oh that's a [ __ ] just
yeah
you can
explode on top
i'll tell you what i missed on but i
know how to make it now so it's time for
me to do a recipe or maybe yeah it's
actually a recipe yeah i really missed
potato scones oh yeah you get them in
scotland the triangles
of of joy
they're just so delicious you can have
them with eggs put them on a sandwich
with anything they're brilliant and
here's how you make them dumb go on
say for instance one evening you're
having a meal and that meal has mashed
potatoes
say you're having a roast chicken
and some vegetables and mashed potatoes
or you're just having vegetables and
mashed potatoes oh you're having sausage
and mashed potatoes or maybe you're just
having mashed potatoes
the most the most deconstructed form of
potatoes you can have i would think
right yeah so you've made your mashed
potatoes make too much dom that's the
secret right make too much when it's
when it's cooled down stick it in the
fridge the next morning
get the mashed potatoes put it in a bowl
and then add
flour
through a sieve
now i don't know how much flour because
i just do it with my eyes and my fingers
but once it becomes like a dough
so it's not potatoes anymore it's a
dough
you take that you roll it super thin
like
eighth of an inch
i
yeah i would say ten playing cards
stacked on top of each other ten normal
sized playing cards
nice and thin
then you cut it into triangles don't do
it triangles is there a reason i don't
know but they're always triangles is it
an old weapon in like scottish clandes
or something like that maybe possibly
and it doesn't matter which type i try
because i know you're not great at
geometry and mathematics i like an
isosceles i don't know what it is though
isosceles it can be a right angle it can
be i don't know what that means obtuse
oh obviously yeah it can be any sort of
triangle you want and you know why it's
maybe triangles i've noticed
it's kind of fun cutting triangles out a
door yeah because
one line can be the side but then you
make it the bottom of the next triangle
and then the top of the next triangle is
a waist or waist it's a way of like
getting around it all surely a square is
less waste than a triangle because
that's real that's everything isn't it
triangle you've missed a little bit
there
no i mean i'll check it out okay but
make it triangles let's let's keep it
traditional
then you get your frying pan nice and
hot
some oil just enough to
you know keep it moist
and then you stick them in fry them fry
them
until it just starts to color
whip it over here here's the thing john
when you whip it you make that noise
here's the thing yeah when you get on
the other side yeah get a good quality
bar oh cut thin and put a couple of
little bits of that on knobs what could
you would you say no but a slither
knob
the the height of one playing card wow
and you put that and then you cook the
other side and then while you're doing
that break an egg fry up an egg or
something
if you have a sausage have a sausage
stop it and then see these potatoes gone
they are the most moorish things you
will ever eat it's like a crunchy
potatoey thing
oh the morning of your wedding i don't
know if you remember because you were
heavily medicated that morning
but the morning of your wedding yeah and
the hilton yeah you woke us up early i
did and it was it was myself elijah a
few notable others your little son was
how old was jack then four three or four
no a little bit older than three five
yeah four four or five yeah and we were
all in our suits and you
you made us all breakfast and it
included your own potato scones and they
were fantastic and i tell you what you
make do yourself a favor and make potato
scones exactly as i told you there
work out the flour consistency yourself
but they are absolutely delicious so
we've done scrambled eggs now we've done
potato scones scrambled eggs and
potatoes oh fantastic we're gonna have
to do at some point a couple of other
things to get as a full breakfast we'll
do a baked bean recipe or maybe
someone's got one for us
maybe a bacon a sausage one if someone's
eating meat or a veggie sausage
we are creating the greatest second
breakfast the perfect second breakfast
send us in your favorite second
breakfast recipes brilliant that's a new
news
this segment is called the perfect
second breakfast lovely
now when we were growing up
everybody loves cereal right i mean what
could be nicer a nice big bowl of cereal
freezing cold milk lovely
but as we get older we realize it's
maybe not the best thing for us there's
lots of stuff in those cereals not to
mention all the sugar
so what do we do we still want cereal
i'll tell you what you do
magic spoon cereal fantastic delicious
and here's some facts
the zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in every serving
only 140 calories are serving it's keto
friendly it's gluten free it's grain
free it's soy free and it's low carb
build your own box
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle are cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry cinnamon cookies
and cream and maple waffle go to
magicspoon.com slash onion and grab your
custom bundle of cereal and be sure to
use our promo code onion at the checkout
to save five dollars off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's packed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee and so it
sure that's delicious so if you don't
like it for any reason they'll refund
your money no questions asked remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
all right you're looking for some new
workout clothes something new to edit
the gym and you're fed up with all the
usual well
i've got the very company for you
viori
clothing now this is one of my favorite
finds of the last few years the ori
clothing is really something special
they're made to work out and so they're
great for the gym or whatever sport
you're doing tennis
surfing i love their surf shops
but as well as that you can wear them
just for lounging around wear them all
day i love their joggers i wear them
basically every day i'll go to dinner
with them they're really great great
clothing and as well as that the company
i try to do something for the planet
the ori is a hundred percent offsetting
their carbon footprint which is
wonderful they are also reducing and
offsetting a hundred percent of their
plastic footprint from 2019 and beyond
really special company that are making
fantastic clothes i would say definitely
try something
the ori is an investment in your
happiness for our listeners they are
offering 20 off your first purchase get
yourself some of the most comfortable
and versatile clothing on the planet at
viori.com
onion that's v
u
o r i dot com slash onion not only will
you receive 20 off your first purchase
but enjoy free shipping on any u.s
orders over 75 dollars and free returns
go to viori.com onion and discover the
versatility of yori clothing
can i tell a lot of ring story
we when we went to a los lorien
which was an amazing set if you remember
and uh i remember one of the carpenters
on it who was making the set
for los lorien was a scottish guy that
i'd worked with
in theater in edinburgh quite a few
times
and i remember speaking with him over
dinner one night and he had the plans of
lothlori and different things
and i said
how's it going and he says this is the
most difficult build he had ever done he
said it was just
incredible the detail that they'd all
went into and when we got there it was
beautiful spiral staircases oh yeah and
all this beautiful elven architecture
you know taken from alan lee's drawings
and john howe
and one of the things they had was this
huge loom if you remember
it's beautiful as if the elves would use
this to kind of make their calls or
whatever
and me and uh
sean aston and i can't were you there i
don't know
i remember this we were sitting at this
loom and it was a bit windy
and the wind blew the loom over and that
hit sean aston
square on his head
crack like it must have weighed about a
quarter of a ton this thing
and it hit him right and hit it
it would have killed a normal man yeah
he's got a big strong head though he's
got a very big head for the size of
manias
and they i think that saved them just
the sheer thickness he's of his cranium
yeah he's solid you would describe sean
aston as a solid man
and i remember after that for good a
good month i would think on set i used
to show
uh sean arson loom
whenever he's walking past me he'd go
yeah that was a beautiful set and i
remember there's a spiral staircase
which features quite a lot in the scene
and obviously there were times where
they would reset our positions so it
kept looking like we were coming around
the corner of the spiral staircase but
to give them their credit that spiral
staircase was quite
uh extensive it wasn't just a couple of
flights of stairs you were on it for a
little bit yeah and then they would
reset us reset the cameras and stuff a
fantastic set a lot laurie beautiful uh
more correspondence from christian
f
three this where's he from greece
carrying out a guess
on our youtube page he simply said i
came to see sam our wonderful critical
role friend but left with a fantastic
scrambled eggs recipe try it out today
my go my goodness it is fantastic thank
you for the recommendation why don't you
try that with potato scones you'd be
crazy not too good shout out um i think
that's it we've got some emails and
voicemails should we do that let's do
let's hear some voicemails let's hear
some some voices
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails
hey billy and dom this is jonathan from
louisiana in the united states the city
of baton rouge which fun fact is french
for red stick
i'm calling because i've always enjoyed
the lord of the rings and though that's
why i found the friendship onion and
your podcast the reason that i've been
fascinated and continue to listen is
your frequent discussions on music and
your opinions on it your viewpoints is
awesome so i had this fun little
question i wanted to leave you guys
other than any of the musical
performance groups that you've already
been a part of if you could at any point
in time
go back and be a part of any other
musical group
what band would it be
and why would you want to play their
music with them
thanks guys have a great one
that's a good one
i'm always so boring i always answer the
be the beatles b.o
i mean
i was watching get back again i just
can't stop watching it i just keep
putting it on it's brilliant we were
saying just before we start the podcast
it's almost become like comfort viewing
you just put it on if you tidy in the
house or washing the pots or something
because it's kind of a long-form
documentary it's brilliant there's this
footage of the beatles in the cavern
kind of around the time where brian
epstein signs them when they're singing
some other guy some other guy now
it's just so joyful and the energy of
that band so
i'm kind of boring i've always wanted to
have some sort of association with
the beatles and they changed music in so
many different ways i mean
but
to not say beatles then please i would
to play live with this band
led zeppelin wow
you know what i mean oh i know what
you're talking about led zeppelin
with that drummer at the back there
giving it the backbeat no i forget that
yeah incredible so so many bands and you
know that film that when when the
beatles disappeared what was that called
yesterday now film where they
disappeared help no the color one no the
beatles weren't in it they disappeared
it was a film that danny boyle made ah
yesterday it is cold yesterday yeah yeah
as a young boy
i basically had that idea
and i used to have little dreams
you know you know when
i think that's a great thing about your
mind mine in particular not everyone's
gone if you if you sit quietly and
really think about something
it's like it's actually happened and as
a young man i used to sit in my room and
i think imagine the beatles didn't exist
and i could have all those songs as if i
wrote them what and and it almost felt
real
well
also it puts forward the argument of
like well what is real right does like
in the matrix your mind makes it real
what
your mind is a powerful thing and your
mind clearly creates things
that you could argue are not real that
it thinks is real because it's projected
on a future that doesn't exist yet and
then also in the present year exactly i
did this i went here i did that you know
like sometimes you're missing
a friend and you and you sit there for a
second and you think oh i wish i was
back in that place with that person
what's happened to your mind there is it
transported you back there exactly yeah
i mean what's i saw a a conversation
with a buddhist monk and they were
asking her what don't you feel like
you're missing out on life and she says
when i sit and meditate i can have any
life i want i can sit i can marry anyone
i can you know and just have these lives
on my head amazing
i don't think that's the right one
uh i think we've got another voicemail
potentially one more yeah
splash i was having a bath
well actually i was having a shower and
it was a fantastic shower because our
good friends over at manscaped their
global leader and below the waist
hygiene had just sent me their new ultra
premium collection and it is fantastic
it's the all-in-one hygiene skin hair
bundle and it's designed to upgrade the
everyday man shower routine from head to
toe and it is absolutely
fantastic
you start off of course when you lather
on the cologne infused ultra premium
body wash it is
really nice then it's hair time that's
when you get your shampoo and
conditioner and then once you're out you
can get your aluminium free deodorant
moisturizer spray
lip balm the whole thing and i tell you
it is really really good they've
absolutely nailed the scent it's not
overpowering it's subtle but it's really
nice and it all has this scent going
through it it's
really really good and i would suggest
you get some and not only get some but
uh don't forget to put the onion code in
to manscape.com because you'll get a bit
off i'll tell you about it
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code onion at manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code onion
at
manscaped.com it's time to get wet and
clean with your new manscaped shower
routine
now what's that sound
that is the sound of another sail on
shopify oh yes and what could be nicer
fantastic shopify is so easy to set up
you can do it without any knowledge of
the insider computers
and it's brilliant shopify gives
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business so the
upstarts start-ups and even established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed
scaling your business is a journey of
endless possibility
oh yes we use shopify here on the
friendship onion and it is fantastic
it's so simple i love how shopify has
the tools and resources that make it
easy for any business to succeed
i mean any business from one down the
street to around the globe
like our shopify powers millions of
businesses from first sale
to full scale
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever growing suite of
channel integrations and apps
it's so easy to add your facebook
instagram tick tock whatever you've got
gain insight as you grow with detailed
reporting of conversion rates profit
margins and beyond it's more than a
store
shopify grows with you
go to shopify.com
all lowercase for a free 14 day trial
and you'll get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features
grow your business with shopify today go
to shopify.com onion right now
shopify.com
slash onion
hey there billy and dominic
uh my name is jacob i am from texas and
i'm actually a teacher
and one of the things i always talk
about with my students is the power of
reading um obviously you have talked
about in your episodes how much you all
have enjoyed reading
and just sort of the impact that reading
has had on you so i was hoping that you
might talk a little bit about
why you think it's important that people
read and even continue to read as an
adult
and then also what do you get out of
reading a book in terms of you know why
do you enjoy reading and why do you
continue to read even to this day
uh thank you very much and hope you all
have a great day
that's a good that's a good question
texas texas teachers
right i was i was speaking to a teacher
and
he was basically saying
that
young people these days are losing the
skill of reading
and
and it's and i get it but also it's kind
of sad
and i think there's a great joy almost
what we were just talking about how your
mind can make a reality well reading is
sort of doing that and
getting comfortable with a book that you
love
and you're looking forward to opening it
up again this is a great feeling and
getting settled and saying i'm going to
be here for an hour or two hours just
sitting reading this book the way you
would with a movie and then your mind
goes into that and it's it's a beautiful
experience but it's one that takes work
yeah as this teacher was saying to me
like our friend in texas there and
it takes work and and i think
young people
just now have a lot of other things and
and things are faster youtube and all
that but i think taking the time to have
a reading space where you like to go
with a book that you're loving is a
is a real joy in life that we we
shouldn't lose
a very simple joy isn't it yeah
i think with all of these art forms that
we're lucky enough to try and interact
with whether that be a tv show or a film
or a piece of art or a poem or a
sculpture or whatever
my personal
feeling of deeply connecting with a book
is really hard to be if you compare it
to anything else it's such a
personal
intimate
experience and also like you said it
does take a little bit of work and i
think sometimes
the intention of saying i'm gonna sit
and read which obviously takes a little
bit of brain power
is an important place to
introduce into your daily habits all the
time a little bit of
education that gives you a little bit of
joy instead of
like you had said sometimes we found
ourselves now in a society where you
just want to just
be as lazy as possible and have things
kind of spoon fed to you you know
yeah and you spend a lot i spend a lot
of time flicking because i don't know
where things are so i'm going from one
thing to another and you know and you
think wow i just
kind of
spoiled
30 minutes or 45 minutes doing nothing
well remember there were times we
stopped doing it because we made it we
made a specific decision to stop doing
it but i would come down to your house
have dinner and then you and i and your
wife would watch like eight trailers to
try and figure out what we wanted to
watch and then have a conversation
realize that two hours have gone by and
i'd be like i gotta get in the car now
so making a decision yeah um
also i'm 45 now
so
i'm also i'm i'm getting quite kind of
specific about reading because i think
well
there's not an infinite amount of books
that i possibly could read no there's
only a finite amount in a good year even
though we make out like we're going to
read tons of books in a year in a good
year
if i've read eight ten books i'm
delighted yeah i think that's good in a
year that's great my friend john johnny
clue's over there johnny clues does a
hundred books i said 100 books last year
is very impressive but he doesn't leave
the house yeah i'll leave the house yeah
you do you're a very ambitious man so
pick up a book and read it what would be
your number one
recommendation for a piece of fiction
fiction fiction he said
rama
go on
rama's a book it's a sci-fi book where
this object comes into our solar system
this is the one they keep talking about
and i keep i always forget the name and
it just came to me there brilliant and
uh
it's called definitely rama it could be
welcome to rama or but i think it's
called rama okay and this
cigar-shaped thing comes in
we don't know what it is but it'd be a
big cigar because it's giant it's really
big
and
when they go up there and they look in
it it's nothing and then very slowly
well actually very quickly
it's the exact opposite
it's like
evolution happens right on the ship on
the ship very like oh water arrives and
then um
small life one cell creatures two
crabs
fish
lizards
monkeys fish yeah and then this all
happens on this thing being witnessed
from earth being what not being
witnessed by the astronauts who go up
there right
and it's giant right right it's like a
seas and i understand
and oh you're not going to ruin it don't
no i won't ruin it maybe i'll read it
and oh enjoy it don't try to think of my
fictional recommendation
there's a great book by richard bach
b-a-c-h
the composer
no
that's uh johan sebastian carry on could
be his uncle uh
it's called illusions you'd like it
it's about a young man who meets the
messiah right in a field right in the
middle of the united states and the
messiah has chosen to take himself out
of his normal
messianic life yeah and just fly crop
dusting planes and he flies around and
he
uh
dusts crops with pesticides and stuff
like that and the guy spends time
getting to know the messiah and being
frustrated and then also inspired by his
relationship with him it's a 100-page
book
very interesting look at
heroes and idols and how that all works
brilliant have you not read that never
read it that's another book i'm going to
buy that will be something like the 15th
book i've bought that's like a year of
books i ca i can't just read your books
for a year true you must be almost done
with that body book i lost it for a
while
i got it i got it back again oh that's
good in it tom what am i reading here
from micah in north carolina right okay
well before i read this i think i could
win this today because you're
you're all fingers and thumbs in your
mouth it's like i've got a nut in my
tongue today
micah from north carolina
here's a little challenge says micah
who's faster at reading the following
there's two of them here go on let's do
the first one right go on then well hold
on we'll need johnny close to timer give
me a time yeah we're one yet time so
billy's are you going first bills yeah
i'll go first then brave man hey tell
you what johnny give us a three two one
go you've got to get it right though
hold on
this is a zither this is a zither a
cricket critic a cricket critic
black bug's blood
i'm ready all right ready i'm gonna say
three two one you want that is that you
seen it
no no no oh i'm just doing practice
three two one or do you want me to three
two one go
three two one go gotta all right ready
yes three two one go how much wood would
a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck would
chuck
it again john all right that's it if you
get it wrong three times three tries
three times in a row you're out right
three two one go how much wood would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could
chuck wood he would chuck he would as
much as he could and chuck as much wood
as a woodchuck would if a woodchuck
could chuck wood fantastic
okay here we go let me warm up a little
bit
isosceles triangle isosceles triangle
isosceles triangle
the statue of liberty
here it goes okay here we go ready yep
three two one go how much wood would a
wood chuck chuck if a woodchuck could
chop wood he would chuck he would as
much as he could and took as much wood
as a woodchuck would if it would chuck
what could you do oh
that was almost a winner
last girl
there's no breakfast
i'm ready are you ready yeah all right
here we go three two one wait wait oh
are you ready i'm ready
yeah three two one go how much wood
would a woodchuck would if a woodchuck
could chop wood he would chuck he would
as much as he could and took as much
wood as a wooden chuck would if it would
just could chuck wood
[Applause]
johnny i would like to um
what do you call it when they throw a
flag on oh wow
i'm not sure i'm not sure about that
first line really how much wood would a
woodchuck
i say it wrong
well we'll see next week
i think we're going right we're good
seconds faster that's amazing we've got
a second one here yeah do the second one
why not i'm sweating johnny yeah don't
worry it's the second one here
i think we should go cold right yeah
should i go first this time
okay ready yeah all right
set
three two one go peter piper picked a
peck of pickled peppers a peck of
pickled peppers peter [ __ ] picked i've
i'm not good at peas no this is going to
be a tough one just to get through okay
john another go ready yep three two one
go peter piper picked a peck of pickled
peppers a peck of pickled peppers peter
panka ah pika last one last one it's
gonna be tough bells this is a tough one
it's a balance between being slow and
correct and fast oh yeah
okay here we go three two one go peter
piper picked a pack of pickled peppers a
peck of pickled peppers peter piper
picked if peter piper picked a peck of
pickled peppers where's the peck of
pickled peppers peter piper
wow 10 57 10 57 there's no chance
i don't think a scotsman has ever even
said this like i couldn't even
speak let's try it here we go all right
give us a journey you're ready three two
one go peter piper picked a peck of
pickled peppers a pack of pickled
peppers peter piper picked a peter piper
picked a peck of pickled peppers where
the peck
you said where
this
i don't know come on
come on no he's quite right he's all
right you've got two more girls and
johnny three that was a winning one that
would have been that would have won
three two one go peter piper picked a
pack of pickled peppers a pack of
pickled peppers peter piper picked if
peter piper picked a pack of pickled
peppers where's the pecker pick him
he's gone okay that would have been that
would have been thai very close to it oh
we got we got some seat problems here
you almost injured yourself there i love
the fact that you've had to do it in an
english accent as well
it you turn into an englishman when
you're a peter piper picked a pegasus
picked a pack of pickled peppers a pack
of pickled peppers peter piper picked
uh
denver dave question yeah we could do a
gin and denver dave questions
okay that was fun that was great yeah
you should do that at home it's good
get the whole family see who can do it
fastest send it to us send us yeah your
tongue twisters yes and tongue twisters
but also tell us who has done one of
those the fastest we would can we put
that up somewhere yeah
we'll put it up on our web pages and all
everywhere as a clip and you can as a
clip but also so you can read it and let
us know do it with your family yeah
saving go along with us see who can do
it fastest my favorite very simple
tongue twister is toy boat just say toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
toy boat
fantastic thanks wasn't that fast but it
was fantastic
so there's a question from
roy campson in new jersey
new jersey
hey jean denver dave wondering what you
[ __ ] think of these gas prices i was
planning on visiting my brother-in-law
in cincinnati it's cost me over 150 to
fill up my truck now i can't afford to
take my bro for honey barbecue wings at
applebee's what the [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] disgrace
thing is i drive a mack truck
so it cost me 480
to get from the top of my street to the
bottom of it so this is not new news to
me that's no [ __ ] use to me it's
terrible right gene i hate it i don't
like these prices i remember when i
could fill up my car for
eight dollars
eight dollars had taken from new york
to north carolina see my grandmother
daisy you should make me some pie
good pie
these prices it's a disgrace no but in
all seriousness tell me about it there
was a point where the gas prices around
the world going crazy brought in in the
united states yeah everything was
[ __ ] hunky-dory now it's not [ __ ]
story
a gallon from florida to [ __ ] san
francisco
and it's all up the wazoo now the
[ __ ] [ __ ] now you're casually
plugged them in the [ __ ] wall i don't
know who's responsible but it's a
[ __ ] disgrace you should buy yourself
one of those little tiny electric cars
that's where you need you get a little
fiat from a a italian and you fill up
that bastard cause she's six dollars no
problem thanks for your question thanks
for the question him come and you piece
of [ __ ]
filthy animal
well
it's always nice to uh hear the opinions
of gene and denver dave
but uh
we should eat the world
it's always my favorite segment of this
show because
sweating from those tongue travelers
tongue travelers now you can't even say
tongue twisters it's that confusing
you're poor man
we will be
heading over to the all expenses spared
stage for another section of billion dom
eat the world
billy and dom eat the world
hello hello you join us here in the
all-expenses spared stage for billion
dollar the world with my wonderful
co-star william boyd hello and we are
eating what i consider to be arguably
the most undermined and
wonderful fruit on the planet a
tangerine no it's this lovely classic
apple
i've never known anyone that eats more
apples than you don't honestly yeah is
that true though because i tell that as
a strong compliment yeah i love apples
and i eat them all the time i know you
do and if someone said to me uh i you're
known as being the person that eats a
lot of apples i'd be like oh well thank
you very much really better than like
saving people and yeah yeah i want to be
the the the king ability but this was
sent to us by uh courtney
click who said here comes danny close
who said uh billy and dom you guys are
so great oh thank you thank you
love the podcast i just wanted to say
thank you you make uh days better whilst
working i run an apple orchards store
and while it's not a greatly exciting
eat the world i hope that you very much
enjoy this snack courtney i will be
getting in touch with you to order some
fantastic apples because look at the
extensive list of apples how many
different types there 50 50 apples
that's incredible what's your favorite
just running just from a name well
my beautiful mom
uh i associate very strongly with a
granny smith apple because i think
that's her favorite so i have a very
soft spot for a granny smith but i'll
tell you what else
i love a pink lady oh no don't we all
william
you ever had never had a some of these
i've never had before a rosa lee a
milton a macintosh a cameo an empire
courtney i'm going to get in touch and
order some of these but
sergey's apples in ohio that's where we
got them from sages apples in ohio and
courtney the wonderful courtney sent us
two different types she sent us a granny
smith
here which doesn't look anything like
the granny smith that i grew up with but
were excited about that and an ever
crisp here read this description here
about an ever crisp
sweet and crisp like you ever chris
makes one of the best eating apples
around what do you mean eating apple
what else you might do with an apple a
bake oreo maybe a baking apple yeah
because you don't want to have like um
i'm going to clean my glasses though oh
yeah good i'm actually using johnny
clues's glasses today because i normally
uh have glasses and i'd like to
introduce them to the billion dollar in
the world section but i keep forgetting
them so i'm using johnny clues's glasses
today which is a shame actually because
johnny clues i just seen him outside
talking to the court stand yeah cassian
thing now which one should we start with
hey a crispy crisper what's it called
forever chris i never crisp now let's
see these how crispy they are because
i'll put this close to the mic
oh my god
from you no wonder i've gone juicy salad
you're salivating not right from the
apple
that is the sweetest stuff i've ever
seen
wow sweet
and crunchy that's as if there's been
sugar like injecting and i don't know
i'll read you some stuff here about the
evercrest the other crisp is sweet and
juicy i just said that
it's a yummy apple that holds a powerful
crunch ever crisp name says it all this
durable apple
arrives late in the season and stores
strongly that means it won't go bad too
quickly
it maintains sweetness like you said and
firmness
like no other that makes evercrisp the
perfect treat for the holiday season and
an ideal snack for a healthy new year my
goddamn
i don't think i've ever had an apple
without knife i love apple now here's
another thing we've talked about ad
nauseam but an apple contains an active
ingredient i think it might be pectin
but that's a guess
the dilates
the gall bladder duct valve it's not is
it not what is it begins with a bee
bumble bee
no no okay but close i could see your
brain working there
so
your gallbladder holds on to certain
toxins and stuff like that and you want
it to be able to release those toxins
unfortunately when gallstones get too
big they get trapped don't they but when
you eat an apple it dilates or or
inflates extends
enlarges
the valve yeah the actual opening
allowing bigger things to fall out well
your gallbladder
bile from your liver comes up to your
gallbladder yeah and then when you eat
something with fat in it
it will release some
it squirts out some bile
to deal with the fat
now you you end up with gallstones i had
them done oh oh i've never seen you
looking so physically and mentally
drained
depend on i've never felt pain like i
know and i used to take because you
you're absolutely right the apples eat
apples drink apple juice and i was and i
used to take the supplement which begins
with a bee
yeah i wish i knew it and then
and it really helped it really helped
but not enough no you had to have
surgery i had to have surgery i tried so
hard i did about a year trying to do it
naturally but i couldn't do it so glad
you bet you lost a lot of weight and you
looked very you looked beside yourself i
was 124 pounds oh that's thin that's
done for me that is thin now a lot of
people talk to me because i am known for
eating a lot of fruit a lot of people
say oh but fruit all that sugar now
here's the thing mm-hmm
almost everything that you eat turns to
sugar in the digestive process a few
things turn to our amino acids and fatty
acids and stuff like that but almost
everything i would say 90 of the things
that you eat turn to sugar the things
that the thing about fruit
apples especially not especially but uh
you know included is it's a sugar that
you know it's fructose so your body goes
ah sugar but we know this it's not like
um man-made sugars that he has to go
through a whole process it's the only
thing you can eat that your body doesn't
have to do anything to it right to
digest it to change it into something
else just immediately uses it instant
energy dom yeah can i try the ground go
on i'm gonna have one last bite of the
ever crisp no thank you girlfriend
courtney our friend courtney says that
um she sent the granny smith as well
because
she heard you saying that you like an
apple on a sandwich
and she thinks this is a good one for
your sandwich yeah my cheese and mama
and crisp sandwich very good right let's
have a bite of a granny smith here we go
oh it's hard is it tough it's a dancer
it's denser though it's firm
like a like a dancer's ass i'm super
solid
oh you're right it's birmingham my front
teeth
oh yeah that's lovely as well
now
yeah would it be fair to say that that's
a little bit more tart oh definitely
more top less sweet
but sometimes you want that in an apple
especially on a sandwich to cut through
some of the cheese and the marmite you
need something a little sharp a little
tart and sometimes when i eat an apple i
don't always want sweet i want
you know i want fresh and crisp and
that's something that makes me go ooh
yeah yeah i like my apples straight out
of the fridge
i personally like to um
give them a little clean with some soap
because
especially in the united states to
preserve them they'll put a little bit
of um
spray on them to kind of hold them in
stasis so i like to wash them with a
little bit of soap and then obviously
dry them but i'll tell you what this is
going to get high scores for me for
usefulness but we'll go on um
so many different flavors here i'm going
to do my research into sages apples in
ohio because it looks like they have a
year
round
selection of apples that you can choose
from and you can find them uh
and we're doing it
and you can find out more at
sageapples.com
if i'm taking a long-haul flight yeah i
will often put a couple of apples in
each pocket because i think you're not
quite sure what you're going to get on
the plane and if i can have two apples i
could skip the first meal and just do an
apple course
that's it one time
when i had my gallbladder problems me
and dom
went to try and sort a natural place
didn't we yeah we did we went to see our
friend linda shea in in north carolina
yeah and it was very helpful but we did
have apples on that flight that's what
made me think about yeah
[Laughter]
read a little blurb here about the
granny schmidt
with its sublimely tart flavor you said
so it was quite tired an unmistakable
green hue the granny smith apple or
malice domestica is one of the most
instantly recognizable apples and
beloved apples in the orchard its
acidity and strong taste make it a
frequent choice for both baking and
eating as a hand fruit
a hand fruit a hand fruit surely most
fruits are hand fruits puffy yeah or
watermelon oh even a watermelon more
like a forearm fruit yeah
fantastic i have to say even though
granny smith's feature
very high in rankings of uh apples for
me on this particular occasion the ever
crisp is uh much preferred do you want
to hear anything about the evercrust
well ancelo's a little bird right
here we go
nearly 20 years ago
mitch linde of lynn fruit farms in
ohio
set out on a mission to develop apple
varieties that were flavourable
flavorful
crunchy and crisp avoiding his regions
unpredictable winter spring weather
patterns and that's when they came up
with the ever crisp and i'll tell you
what
delicious it's an instant classic it's
fantastic absolutely
so we're scoring both apples separately
i say or are we pooling them together i
think we do it separately don't we
really we'll need to be fast then we'll
run that the same all right the honey
crisp right flavor
it's an 8.9 for me that's a nine for me
wow you loved it
uh aesthetics i mean i like the fact
that it's all clearly organic so you
know it's not the most uniform of shapes
but i enjoy that i'm giving it an eight
main head this little guy that i'm
always i'm almost worried that i'll find
a half a worm yeah could it could be
just be a minor bruise yeah surface but
i think it's beautiful and i'll give
that a nine as well okay great
usefulness my god an apple you can put
it in a cake you can put it in ice cream
you can put it in some sort of pie you
can have it
juice it it helps it got a smoothie it
helps with gall bladder issues it's
healthy you can take it on planes it's
portable you can train games training
automobiles all of them it's a 10 out of
10 for me for usefulness across that
i don't think i've ever given it in a
10.
and i want to have for some things but
not across the board
really
i think you have but that's all right
what's this
no it's a 9.5 9.5 and then onto the
granny smith taste i'm going to get is
slightly demoted to me because i didn't
it wasn't the greatest grindsmith i've
had i'm going to give it a 7. i hear you
dom it's nice it's tart but not tart
enough if i'm as as
you know going against this one yeah
it's not firm enough for me
and you could hardly get your teeth
through it i know i want it firmer it
okay uh aspects the look of the thing
it's not the most attractive granny
smith i've seen either i'm gonna give it
a 6.5
eight
usefulness is a ten out of ten
i mean it's incredibly useful if
anything maybe even more useful than
this one so 9.8
well that was in my opinion the most
underrated
and uh much maligned through out there
because i think it's familiarity breeds
contempt you see because
i'm doing a job no you set me up for
that my feelings there no but if you
suddenly were introduced to a banana or
an apple we'd all go crazy about it but
because we're so used to growing up with
it you think oh whatever an apple but
it's brilliant size for your hands yeah
brilliant flavor everyone loves an apple
do you know anyone that doesn't like
apples everyone loves an apple well if
it's a good apple it's a good apple
isn't it yeah but the thing i always do
is i'll leave them too long
and then i'll pass and i'll go oh i
could go an apple and i get it and it's
it's past its best
i like it when it's crisp
you've got to go after it my brother
used to eat a whole apple core no oh you
couldn't do that
didn't do it anymore the seeds are
poison
is it a tiny amount of cyanide i think
so so never put the seeds in a smoothie
or anything never put a whole apple in
right
keep the colour out
dom here's a some here's nothing to do
with ohio and the lovely people that
courtney said
apple.com but why is the big apple
called the big apple
and you know this because we wanted it
in new york
we've been told this before do you know
the answer i do know the answer um don't
give us a clue is it some something
about an industry something about a
trade
but it's not about fruit industries well
it's sort of
well new york
used to be the big apple um
center a producer of america right
and but why did they call it the big
apple and who called it the big apple
i'm gonna say well they called it the
big apple because that's where most of
the apples in the country were being
farmed so it was yeah
and then it was and then it was
nicknamed the big apple by
frank sinatra oh
louis armstrong maybe armstrong went to
the moon
jazz musicians
when they were on tour in america the
biggest gigs were always in new york so
when they were going there they say
that's us we're going to the big apple
and i think
a lot of jazz trumpeters yeah would buy
an apple and store it in the cone
are you sure so you don't get dust in
there but also when they went for a
really high note
sometimes make the balcony yeah um
fantastic piece of apple trivia there
courtney thank you thank you for these
wonderful fruits and i'll certainly be
getting in touch with you to um see if i
can get hold of some more because it's a
great apple absolutely delicious they
described some of these uh apples as
spicy that's crazy a male rose you can
have a spicy apple anyway
guys get in touch with us if there's
something that you grew up with if
there's a delicacy that you've tried a
couple of times and you want us to try
it because it's it's a a curious food
item or something like that get in touch
with us uh
billion dom eat the world uh
i forgot the email address don't worry
about that dom i'll do it now the
friendship onion at castmedia.com yeah
or you can get in touch with us leave
comments on our youtube channel or you
should follow our spotify playlist
rate review and subscribe to us because
if you subscribe to us it means that we
can make more episodes
thank you very much thanks thank you for
all the apples
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host the baby you're my pearl
[Music]